with restaurants bars and theaters
closed Americans are finding themselves
with plenty of time for solitary
activities like reading well one
bookstore in Washington DC is staying
open offering readers unique access to
its shelves while still being mindful of
social distancing Christina Ruffini has
the story
from the sidewalk outside Capitol Hill
books looks like most of the shops on
this street closed so what's upstairs so
on the second level we have all of our
fiction poetry but if customers make an
appointment and use the mandatory gloves
and hand sanitizer they can have all
three floors and thousands of volumes to
themselves basically they can own the
bookstore for now something like that
we'll set up a one-hour time block for
them to come in and kind of browse the
books Kyle Burke says he and his
co-owners were looking for a way to
support their five full-time employees
during the coronavirus lockdown the
first day private sessions posted all of
them booked out our sales are definitely
off a little bit from what they normally
would be but it was just enough to keep
us viable like many Washingtonians Alex
Stark and Andrew Lieber have been stuck
in their small shared apartment
they say they jumped at a chance to
safely go shopping and browse the
cluttered chaotic stacks books can be an
incredible learning experience but also
a great way to escape and that's
especially nice when you don't have that
much stimulation or or access to the
outside world and with current events
reading more like some of the shops
dystopian fiction employees are also
offering a curated quarantine collection
including Chairman Mao's Foreman at
physical fitness plan if communists cal
aesthetics aren't your thing poetry
seems to be a crowd favorite finally if
you're looking for a tale of someone who
successfully survives social distancing
kind of Montecristo the main character
edmond dantes is in the Chateau d'If for
six years by himself those books I was
supposed to read in high school and and
didn't so definitely the time to read it
you might want to check the last line My
dear replied Valentine has not the count
just told us that all human wisdom is
contained in the words wait and hope
it's pretty apt at the end of their hour
Alex and Andrew made an eclectic
selection and headed back home with a
backpack full of distractions for
whatever comes next
I worry but I'm also I feel really or I
feel pretty confident that folks are
kind of coming together just kind of
supporting each other it seems like a
really difficult time but I think we'll
get through with a few good books to
help pass the time in isolation all
that's left to do is wait and hope for
CBS this morning Saturday Christina
Ruffini Washington crisis or no crisis
books are the best especially when you
hold the physical book yes love that
love that sorry it's it's great stuff